spring is in the air and for a lot of us
that means getting a fresh start with
your pet
petrendologist charlotte reed is here to
talk about some top
seasonal tips charlotte it's good to see
you again this morning it's
always great to see you john how are you
i'm doing just fine good to see
you've got the canine in place as well
now we should talk about
getting ready as you mentioned for
spring you know here in in las vegas
a lot of people work on their gardens
kind of year-round but what should pet
owners
know before they go to the pet stores
before maybe they make some additions to
their backyard to their gardens
well that's a great question and you're
absolutely right the garden centers are
packed
i bought a beautiful pant it's called a
duranda it's actually australian in
nature
but this plant is beautiful it is with
its purple leaves
is deadly all parts of the plant
including
the little seed pods that come out are
bright orange and they fall to the
ground and a lot of times pets eat them
and immediately lead to renal failure
not only for dogs cats
but if you have a mister at a horse it
could also really be detrimental
causing a huge vet bill so before you
buy
it's a really good idea to check the
aspca toxic and non-toxic plant list
just pull it right up on your phone at
the garden center and make sure you're
buying
a safe plant for your pet yeah the worst
thing you'd want to do is make some
addition to your backyard and obviously
it would cause some problems down the
line for your
for your pet pets that are eating things
they are allowed to eat
maybe they're doing a little bit more of
that during the pandemic we've all put
on a few pounds possibly
uh what are some ways to try and get our
pets a little bit more
slender during the springtime well john
you look good and i haven't gained a
pound i've actually
lost a few pounds so i'm happy about
that but yeah i mean
there are a lot of fat pets they're
obese
american pets are just like their owners
about 55 percent of 58
of dogs about 54 of cats are obese and a
lot of people don't realize the older
they get
the worse it gets so obese pets at any
age suffer from
arthritis joint disease
cardiac problems diabetes all human
ailments and the pets are suffering from
the same thing
it's a really good idea to start your
pet on a diet talk to your vet about it
you know
you might change your food he might
encourage you to do exercise
i actually like this slim pause program
which is
available for large medium and small
sized dogs really it's
safe because it's lab tested and double
blind tested
but it's a little chewy as you can see
right here i'll just hold it up
you give it to them once a day in the
morning before or after they eat
and literally in 12 and and literally
your pet in 10 weeks can lose 12 pounds
it's easy to find it's on amazon it's a
petsmart and it's at slimpaws.com
so you can help make your pet happier
healthier and actually more mobile
by losing those weight by losing that
weight that'd be fantastic again
especially you know it's one thing to
get your dog
or your cat maybe i guess your dog more
importantly out for a walk go running
around in the park while you're kind of
cooped up at home during the pandemic
but it's also about
making sure the dog gets a chance to eat
what's uh what's right
i'll take it from here john thank you
charlotte reed thanks for uh for joining
us you joined us yesterday to chat a
little bit about dogs and
pets and everything nate you are with us
but this is not this is now
present day yeah that was a little
existential there josh well we like to
try and mess people's minds
well it's working you know as you
mentioned a lot of folks added to their
houses uh during the pandemic with
fostering pets or adopting pets so
you've got to make sure you do it right
here as we get into the warmer months of
the year